um
[Music]
we have uh
this morning uh emmanuel and uh enrique
and fedor are gonna all together uh tell
us about learning staircases and i think
emmanuel uh will start from luzon right
yes exactly okay
okay thanks uh hi everyone i don't see
you but uh uh
i i suspect that uh
it's good to be physically meeting i
hopefully will make it to the next one
but at least we have theo and enrique
that are going to
pick up and take over the talk soon
so yes so uh this is the topic and you
know the first the question is the same
as we had in the previous
talks of this collaboration
we want to understand what in the
setting of
of deep learnings of combining over
parameterized nets with gd
what is the
sufficient and necessary meaning how
sufficient is the framework is it you
know back is it less what is the class
of architecture and functions that work
well together
and also is it necessary to go to this
framework or could we get away with
kernels and what is necessary in the
framework
okay so these questions it seems like
you know to answer them it matters what
is the class of neo-net architectures
and initialization that we allow
uh and this spectrum is kind of
you know the range of complexities we
can have at the very left here you see
my mouse moving
so at the very left here
uh you know it's like the most
structured and regular architecture you
know fully connected two-layer
uh with ii initialization
and then you know as you evolve you get
the through you know more practical
architecture and at the very right
extreme
this is what i refer to free networks
with just you know anything you want in
your architecture as long as it has
polynomial number of edges
and you know you can also initialize as
you want
so in you know in the past years with a
few uh collaborators we looked at the
right extreme
and this is kind of the summary of the
picture in this right extreme so in in
the world where all the parameters that
you care about scale polynomially so i
won't define things more precisely
because i want to move on to the new
stuff but in this word
when you train neural networks that are
free with sgd it turns out that you can
get everything that's efficiently packed
learnable but that is efficiently
learnable from
poly many samples
if you insist on using full population
gradients with some
noise uh that is polynomial then you
will saturate um sql and you know in
this recent paper with natty and others
we got the in between picture as well
which is i mean we don't have the full
picture but the fairly tight uh
characterization of what you can get if
you have a batch size b and some
precision noise on your gradients and
there's some sort of threshold phenomena
that you either get to back or sql
okay and we also know that this is
strictly better than what you can do
with kernels so that's the picture in
the free world
and you know
the fact that the answer to yes sgd with
freenets can get back is you know
it's nice to know it lets you it allows
you to dream because the answer is yes
but the actual solution of how we get
there
doesn't seem to explain much about how
real neural networks
are learning and what's missing in this
picture
is that you know
in many applications the neural nets
don't try to do what we do in those
papers which is you know emulate other
algorithms but they actually manage to
learn features hierarchically
from initialization that is fairly black
box that doesn't you know encode too
much about the problem at hand of course
you know
this statement is is hard to quantify
because a if you look at what really
google uses it's pretty far from a two
layer fully connected and b you know
it's still very quite specific
application images etc but still
if you look at regular nets with you
know homogeneous layer iid stuff it
still learns a fair amount of functions
and not in a way by emulating certain
algorithm okay so we want to understand
this hierarchical aspect that is missing
in the picture of the previous slide
and so let's move to the extreme left
of the spectrum of complexities and and
look at this irregular networks or
initialization
so we will you know we will define what
we mean by uh what the type of nets we
use in the theorems but for now i will
stay fairly high level
by regular i mean that you know you put
edges
between a certain number of layers in an
independent fashion uh across uh between
any pair of layers you also put edges
that could be long edges from the input
to the middle in the in an
independent iid fashion and also from
the middle to the output if you want but
all of this must be done with some
properties for each type of edge which
is you know iid and you put the weights
on these edges also from an iid
distribution so in particular at each
layer if you apply a permutation of the
neurons at initialization you must have
the same distribution
okay so again a bit more on the setup we
will care about boolean function
we denote
the d to be the input dimension
calligraphic f is typically the class of
function the hypothesis class we want to
learn
we get samples where the input is
uniform on the boolean cube
and we'll train
in most results we use the l2 loss
again the parameters we use is a little
n for the number of samples and capital
n for the widths of the net or for the
number of features
now once you have a boolean function
uh
we know that you can decompose any such
boolean function into its free basis
which essentially means that
you can decompose such function in terms
of the monomials
which are here the chi s
the monomials that look at the variables
in subset s
and f out of s will be the fourier
coefficient
okay so we want to understand what kind
of boolean function or boolean function
class we can learn
from such regular type of architectures
and you know what we started with is uh
what many people also looked at is what
happens when you look at a single basis
element which is
you know you want to see
the sky s
uh when is it that we can learn them
so you know we know that if the power of
your monomial
is large we know that from sq or from
the stuff we had in the in the universal
setting that we get into trouble if you
have population gradient or huge
batch
but uh now we are asking slightly
different questions because uh
we are not allowed to uh to do some kind
of uh emulation so we cannot do the
university results because we are forced
to use a regular net so let's just do
some experiment with
a resnet
with five layers width is 40
and we use sgd with you know a moderate
size for the batch
and we can see that
of course as expected if capital p the
power of the monomial is one so the
function is just linear it learns pretty
quickly
uh that makes sense
it's a fairly easy function to learn but
as p increases quite soon for 10 already
it gets nothing you know after even 100
000 iteration of sgd
okay so uh it seems like if you stick to
this basis element
uh pretty quickly as the power becomes
you know not small
already such fairly big neural net get
into trouble
okay so
is this then uh what's happening if you
go beyond monomials if you now take
mixture of monomials which is you know
what happens in more general boolean
functions you know is it that the answer
is simply that you can only learn
polynomials that are finite degree that
have low degree
and um and the first in your remark is
that this is uh of course not true and
here is a simple case where
you can go to high degree and still
learn and this is what we call the
vanilla staircase where you get to a
hagrid degree term here so the p here
could be as large as you want
but you know you get there in a very
specific form which is that you have a
hierarchy of coefficients that are
nested into each other
so the key here is that the low degree
terms are helping the high degree terms
if you try to learn these with a neural
net it will probably pick up the
dominant term which is the linear term
x1 and once it has x1
you know if you look at the next term if
you factor out x1 then it's again a
linear term and if you factor out x1 x2
in the third term then it's again you
know just the linear term which is you
had x3 so it looks like this could be a
useful
to learn for you know regular nets and
in fact if you do this experiment
uh you see that this happens that you
can learn a staircase of degree 10 so
recall that before just the last
coefficient will not be learned at all
this is this plot here on the right but
now if you work with the staircase then
you will learn the whole staircase and
you can learn the last term
uh uh with perfect accuracy and on top
of this it's the the way that those four
three coefficients are learned is done
hierarchically in the sense that you
first start learning as expected the
linear terms then the quality can you
know you pick up
uh each higher degree
successively as the number of iteration
goes up
okay so what the next question that we
wonder at this point was like okay is
this class of staircase function so i
mean the class because you can take a
permutation of you know all the
functions obtained by
applying permutation on the input so you
can do x7 plus x7 x9 etc and is this
just you know an instance of an
efficiently sq learnable function class
and is this what we are going after with
with this approach that maybe we're
trying to argue that with regular nets
we will also be able to get nes in sq
um and so to see why this is not the
case consider the following truncated
staircase where you start with the
monomial of the bj as opposed to degree
one and you climb to a monomial of the k
okay so they are nested but you go from
degree j to k
and what happens is that
as long as you don't break the steps
either at the beginning or the end so at
least if either at the beginning of the
end
you can
go on the staircase so you can either
climbing climb it or you can go down the
staircase then this will be sq learnable
and the reason for that is that
you know if you know that you go all the
way up so let's say that you you you
know the staircase ends
or almost ends you can pull out a few
constant terms but almost ends with the
full monomial then you can still learn
it with sq because you know the full
monomial is there
and so now you can see okay i'm going to
try to learn which one is the next
monomial that is nested into this one
there's only
uh d uh potential monomials to drop one
element so you can check for all these d
monomials and figure out which one is
there with an sq query and then you can
peel out this guy and go down the
staircase hello yes yes can you clarify
a bit what do you mean by sq learnable
because this is a specific function do
you mean like a function class
through the lp yeah
yeah i don't know that's what i meant
with the permutation command so if you
if you apply permutation on so if
instead of this the function was x7 plus
x7 x8 because x7 x8 x9 so all the class
of functions that have the property that
you know it's a nested change of
coefficients this creates a cluster
function that we call the staircase
class
or the vanilla staircase class
thanks so differently the class of
functions are this
form for any permutation right exactly
okay thanks
and what i meant is as long as either at
the beginning or at the end you're you
don't have a jump you start with degree
one or you start with maximum degree you
could still in both cases you could
still learn with sq because you know
that you can start either at the
beginning or at the end and you can
either climb by figure out with s2
queries which of the degree of degree
one monomial you have if you go up and
if you go down you just figure out which
of the the of the monomial you have to
drop
and in both cases
this would be sq learnable
uh and and and it doesn't uh require you
to climb up the staircase or go down
it's it's learnable with sq but the
point is that this is not learnable if
you want to run it with a regular net
and the problem is that the regular net
what it does as an input are the degree
one monomial
so if you feed x1 x2 x3 as input to your
neural nets
and it's regular
then you will not know how to go down
and so you need
any staircase that uh
as the beginning the first steps that
are broken
the neural net with sgd will have
trouble uh finding a path to go up the
staircase and now in some cases we can
argue that so that's not the part of
this talk but this is just to say okay
so this class of function
is not something that uh what you can
learn with regular net doesn't seem to
be the entire sql class because of this
the next question is you know are we now
overshooting is the class of staircase
only what you can do with kernels
uh many meaning that maybe now we have
actually a pretty simple class of
function
and the answer is also no that you know
if you have staircases that have a
growing degree these are not kernel
learnable but they will be actually
learnable by regular net as we will uh
discuss in this talk
um so what is the
i'm going to now tell you a bit about
this part of why circuses of growing the
degree are not kernel learnable
and first of all we know already that
this would be the case for certain
kernels like ntks or for random features
models
and the reason for that is that any such
function not necessarily staircase we
know that the required number of samples
or minima of samples and number of
features to scale
a polynomially with a
d to the power k where k is the degree
and uh so if k grows then of course you
will need super point number number of
samples or our features
and and that's why you will be in
trouble for these specific models
now the question we ask is also can we
have a marginal results that shows that
no matter what your kernel is you know
even if you try to be smart and you know
that it's a you know that the function
class is staircase so you can maybe say
okay i'm going to put
all my degree one monomial and then i'm
going to specify the degree k with some
proper specification etc so could we
argue that no matter what is the number
of features we use and capital n that is
polynomial
we will always be in trouble to learn a
staircase of growing degree
and the reason why this is not
completely obvious is because at least
to our knowledge that the tools that are
available in literature that goes with
statistical dimension arguments
they typically look like this so here
i'm quoting uh from the the paper of
nutty encoder uh you lure about the min
max loss uh by the trivial uh loss so we
are normalizing all the functions to
have norm one
the minus something that depends on the
number of features
and the static statistical dimension of
the class
which for classes like staircases will
be polynomial because you can you can
learn this with this cube
and so if this is uh done if the the
denominator is polynomial in theory you
could take a large number of polynomial
feature and not make this bound you know
uh going to one
uh so how do we get around this is a
simple trick we is the following lemma
we will decompose the set of all boolean
function into the direct sum
of the boolean function that have degree
less than c
and the boolean function of that degree
at least c
and then we just lower about the
contribution of the loss of the optimal
loss into these two edges this is the
edge you get when you look at all
features of degree at most c and you
don't care that we only are supposed to
use n
here we can afford taking all of them
because we will take c small enough
and now we have this kind of edge here
that looks only at features now we have
capital n of them but these are features
that have that must have degree at least
c
and uh what's beneficial is that if you
apply this type of bound on this
projected problem when you must have a
certain degree then you can actually get
this time a bound that is vanishing as
long as n is polynomial
so i i
i can okay i
give a little bit more details but not
much but essentially
so you look at this class of staircase
function normalize to abnorm one
uh of degree p
and um and you pick a cutoff which is
root p for this degree
and this makes up the first contribution
the blue one
of all features that can have the grid
must see is going to be vanishing
because c is growing so you know there's
no way that uh
is growing slowly so this is going to be
not enough uh to capture the fact that
you have root p for the degree when the
true staircase goes all the way up to p
and now you pull out the n on the second
contribution
and the good news is that this term
which is kind of playing the role of you
know what you have in in in this
original bounds but in the projected
space this term is going to be also
vanishing
because you know you only have uh you
can still have a lot of terms that are
below root p that you're ignoring
and so you know you can control both
terms and that's how you show that
oops sorry that's how you can show that
no matter how the kernel you use as long
as the staircase has growing degree you
cannot learn it
if you have n polynomial
okay so this is just to say we are doing
more than kernels with the staircase
functions
and now the question that remains is can
we actually learn them you know we know
that
you can you can they are not sql they
are modern kernels but you know we'd
like to understand if we can learn them
with regular nets
and um and in the first paper we have uh
which is with this author you know
presented now at eurips
what we show is the following so we
generalize a little bit this class of
function this is you know the very very
the doubly vanilla staircase but the
marginally what we call the valence
staircase is
any function with poly many terms of
polynomial magnitude for the
coefficients
such that any non-zero fourier
coefficient contains another non-zero
free coefficient of one degree less or
is an input
so it could be what i wrote there or any
permutation of that or it could be a
staircase which has multiple branches
that leave you know like for example x1
you can go a pass that goes x1 x2 etc
but you can go another path that go x1
x3 and take another branch
so as long as you have this vanilla
staircase property what we can show is
that radian-based learning on a regular
nets but that i will
mention a little bit more
in 30 seconds what this nets we use can
learn these vanilla staircases in
polytime so that's the positive results
it's it's a regular net but it's still
not you know uh uh i as a regular as uh
what we will discuss in the next part of
the talk it's it's a sparse net where
you know we put edges
uh we we put a lot of width the the
depth is d is p is the is the degree of
the staircase but we make enough widths
and we make the net sparse enough such
that we kind of a little bit give hand
to the sgd algorithm by making sure that
you know each uh
neuron has at most uh two
parents and so we kind of give a bit a
hand uh to the analysis so that it makes
it easier to each time recursively learn
the product of the previous term with
the new input
so it's still uh regular in the sense
that it satisfies all this permutation
in variance and that break the emulation
argument we have in the
in the in the other papers but it's
still not fully uh seeing how the
features can be are being built for
example
in uh in a dense uh regular nets like a
two layer uh min field net etc
so this is yes
so what does it mean here in this
theorem gradient based learning
yeah so that's the second part yeah so i
was about to say uh the it's also not a
standard uh
hdd what it means that we do between
each layer is layer wise sgd
but also we train a neuron repeatedly
to mitigate our propagations that we
have a training so it's still you know
not the classical sgd
where you know you just train uh
it's it's gradient-based but it's not
you know uh uh ideally the the sgd would
like to analyze
it's it's neuron-wise training
uh it's it's uh it's uh you train each
neurons in uh in a layer
each sequentially so each neuron
separately yeah that's like neuron
right
so anyway that's the the end of my part
and i i think uh the point we want to
make is uh we exactly want to go beyond
this theorem and that's what the enrique
until we present
you know we don't want you we we had
something that was irregular but still a
little bit uh hacky once we allowed us
to be regular and now we want to switch
to you know more standards type of
neural nets uh denser and also classical
sgd analysis and also we don't want to
be any more in the polytime lens but we
want to go to how things scale exactly
with number of samples and time steps
so that's the the end of the the first
part and i guess to you will take over
thanks
thank you
i'll stop sharing
if you can leave this thing okay
yeah
all right so with enrich
i will consider a more restricted
setting
and i will consider a staircase with
bounded degrees
and
okay so actually we'll
take a step back
and we'll consider like a slightly
more general setting in this banded
setting
which is learning sparse functions on
the hypercube
so we'll take uh so data x uniformly
distributed
on the hyper cube in d dimension
and we'll consider y to be noisy
measurement of a target function f star
and so we'll assume that f star is
p sparse
uh so that means that there exists i 1
to i p so indices so unknown
so that f star only depends on this
subset of coordinates
and in this section we'll consider p to
be bounded and d
large enough
so why
is this setting interesting
so for linear models i said that
such as random features and kernel
methods so they are oblivious to
sparsity
and are only adaptive to the smoothness
of the target function
so let me
give a concrete example so to learn a
degree k polynomial on the hypercube
so random features and
inner product kernels we need the number
of random features n
and number of sample
small n
that scales with d at the power k
and so no matter the structure of the
polynomial
so for example if it's parson non-sparse
it will still need
to scale with d at the power k
so on the other hand
we expect no networks to be able to
adapt to sparsity
and to uh
sometimes like vastly outperform
tessellina
methods
so this is clear from an approximation
point of view
but actually proving that for gradient
based
uh like gradient-trained neural networks
it's uh it's
quite a challenge and there is uh almost
no work doing that
so okay so we consider a piece path
degree k target function f star on the
ipad cube so just note that
uh because we're on the eye picture but
this path function is at most degree p
um
and so we'll ask two questions
so the first one like um
inspired by this linear methods so can
we show that for some estar
vanilla gdsgd train no networks can
learn with a number of neurons big and
number of samples for small n that
scales as d at the power c with c much
smaller than chemistry
and this will uh this would
immediately imply a separation result
between
kernel methods
linear models
and gradient training neural networks
and again there's like only a few
examples
that show that
so second question so more interesting
so what properties on ester allows for
efficient learning with gdsgd
okay
so here what do i mean by vanilla gdg
train neural networks
so we take
uh the simplest non-network so like
which is like the two-layer neural
network with
uh so big n neurons
uh so parameters theta i so a i a scalar
w i
uh vector in rd
uh so wi first layer weight ai second
layer weight
and just notice that here i normalized
by one over n so this is the
min field normalization
and so we consider a test error with
square loss
and we'll run sgd on both players
so
nothing more no black box no
dark magic
and so
here lgd will be okay so we initialize
with
id weights uh with initialized
like initial
distribution row zero
and so i teach step k we sample x k y k
and so update the weights
uh so eta here will denote the step size
and we did not take a
the weights like obtained after k
iterations of this sgd
and so this is
uh
like quite challenging to study directly
so we use an approximation min field
approximation
and so what we'll assume is that
we use new fresh samples at each
iteration so the xkyk are id so we're
doing a one pass hd
this is like the important
assumption here for like this mean field
approximation to work
uh so we can like uh change the learning
rates we can uh
do batch as you did them in like
important thing is that at each
iteration we use new fresh samples
so with this assumption so
cell groups in 2018 showed
that
the empirical distribution of the
weights
theta i
obtained after
t over
eta
lgd steps
so they like at this empirical
distribution converge weekly to row t
so distribution on the space of
parameters so d plus one-dimensional
and so it converges as the number of
neurons n goes to infinity
and
the step size goes to zero
and that is 30 is given by
so the evolution of 40 is given by this
distributional dynamics
so with initialization so row zero
and that's pde and just note that
the null network now is you know just a
integral over
the distribution of rooty
okay
so how well does this mean field
approximation fair
so
we'll do a few assumptions
so we'll assume that the response and
the noise are bounded
that the activation function is twice
differentiable
i will assume that
sigma sigma prime and sigma prime are
all bounded
and i will assume that the
initialization was zero has
banded support on a
and so from a previous paper with song
and on there we proved the following
bound
so the null network trained by
sgd
uh
is a close energy distance to the null
network trained by min field pde
at two time t so it's bounded by like
this formula
and so the only thing to notice is that
so k only depends on the assumptions
above assumptions and so in particular
it will be independent of d and p
so just another remark about this bound
so for t and k so if you consider them
constant
so the mean field approximation is
accurate
as long as the number of neurons is
bigger than a constant
and the same size is smaller than one
over d
and just note that uh because we have
this one pass assumption the number of
samples is just t over uh eta
and so like the number of samples just
needs to be uh bigger than the
constant
okay
uh so so far i didn't use anything about
f-star so
now uh we can just look at what happens
when f-star is
sparse
this parse
so we take x the circle variety
so we
decompose it in a z-part which is a
single part p-dimensional
r which is the non-informative part of
the input
we take
the weights also we decompose it in
u and v so you align with the
signal part and v aligned with the
non-informative part of the input
so if we take initialization
s0w0 is w0
uniform on the hypercube
then the pd's permutation variant in the
last d minus p coordinates in particular
the weights
uh of the neural network that are
aligned with the non-informative part of
the signal will just be rescaled
by we'll just evolve regularly
with a coefficient st yes
yeah row a is just the initial initial
uh
like a
distribution for a
so just uh
a and w are initialized uh independently
on both layers and just assume that a0
is distributed with row a and row a like
so far we don't assume anything oh yeah
like yeah it's confusing i guess yeah a
is not a time pointer
um
yes so dt is the t
coordinate how comes
permutation invariant implies that you
adjust the voltage oh
oh it's just because uh so
x uh so like r will also be uh
uh so you can uh
um
yeah so you can uh absorb visio in r
which is also uniform on the hypercube
so this is actually not very important
here
so you can like take a more general
uh
like
distribution uh
initial distribution if it's isotropic
it will also work
uh i mean it won't be uh
uh like you won't have like this nice
rescaling of mvt
but uh like what i will say next will
also work
so the point is uh here just to give a
concrete example how it can work so here
uh we have uh we can then write the
equivalent dynamics
so instead of being deep first
one-dimensional it's key plus
two-dimensional
so now the parameters are a zero u-0 and
s-0
so u-0 is like the p-dimensional
weights
aligned with the signal and so as zero
is
initialized with equal to one a0 has the
same initialization of before and using
also two
and uh so here we have like this
equation so i won't go into the details
and i just mentioned that now the neural
networks only depend
on
z
also the signal part
and here
i take d goes to infinity in this uh
equations
so what happened is that u0 is a
p-dimensional vector
with entries that are plus minus one
over square root of d
so when d goes to infinity you can
approximate zero by just as your vector
st evolves at a rate t over square root
of d i mean s minus 1 is bounded by t
over square root of d
so for finite time
when d goes to infinity you can assume
st constant so equal to one
and so if you look at for example this
so s equal one and now you take the
expectation of an r
so like i just you have a
sum of ready marker divided by square
root of d and so this is uh just
converges to a gaussian
and so we
introduced this sigma bar which is a
smooth activation
what's this gaussian
and so what we
get at the end so when d goes to
infinity we get is what i call the
dimension free
dynamics
so dimension freeze because like this it
doesn't depend on d anymore
so
we have a zero distributed as before u0
that has like zero initialization
uh and we have these equations
and now we have a new network
with a p dimensional input z
and a smooth activation
sigma bar
and just so what did we do
we started from this mfpd
which is a gradient flow on the space of
neural networks
with d plus one parameters
with
disinitialization
and when
d goes to infinity replaced it by this
equivalent gradient flow
on p plus one dimension
and with any saturation so first layer
weights are equal to zero
and the difference between the two
dynamics up to time t is bounded by this
quantity
and so if we merge the two previous
bounds
oh it's when d goes to infinity uh so
uh here what i did
so here like
uh so
yeah i took uh
oh
infinity
here like so here we have like the exact
equations
and we take d goes to infinity here to
replace u zero by zero uh st equal one
and uh we replace this expectation over
r by expectation over aggression
the
symmetry is still is valid for anybody
which is yeah the approximation
is when because
exactly
anticionisation and the rescaling is t
equal to one
um
[Music]
so we get this bound and when we
uh
like uh
like merge the two uh like combine the
two previous bounds we guessed this
error when we
approximate
the sgd train null networks
by the null networks obtained by the
dimension free dynamics
and
i just mentioned again k is independent
of
dnp
and so in particular
if this dfpd achieves
tessera epsilon in time t
so
uh because it only depends on f star
epsilon and rho s so t will only depend
on f star it's an n right
then there exists a c
that only depends on k t and epsilon so
that
for any d bigger than c p n
number of samples bigger than c d and
number of neurons big n bigger than c
uh one passes gd with step size
uh like eta equal
t over n achieves uh
like a risk of other action
okay
so this motivates uh like one important
definition for the rest of the talk
which is uh sgd learnability in od
scaling
this is like motivated by this
so what does it mean it means that for
any asean
there exists t star c star so that
for any
d so ambient dimension yes
number of samples
so the number of samples is t over
like here it's one passes gd and we're
just counting the number of steps that
will make it
okay so we
so
for any action there is sister and
sister so that for any d bigger than
sister p
number of samples n bigger than sister d
and number of new ones are bigger than c
star so one pass a gd with step size
like test over and achieves absent risk
and so here again like we can
replace by batch sgd
as long as it's one pass
so okay so what's uh
so what is this definition saying so
it's a kind of a scaling law for
vulnerability of f-star
um it means that for any d arbitrary
large
big-o of these samples is sufficient to
learn it
and so then like the caveats are it's
one passage but okay so for example if
you take the number of samples d at the
power one plus epsilon because your
converges very quickly
uh to uh zero uh you
i mean you will only reuse like a few
samples
this is pretty mild
the other thing is that we
have been filled uh parametrization so
uh depending on you it's rather like
uh the right thing to do or not
okay so here's the definition
aren't you concerned about how large
t-star c-star
so here they don't depend on d so like
here we only care about uh
the dependency indeed
oh so you're saying yeah
sister and sister are dimensional
independent
so yeah so this is uh i mean i comment a
bit more about this
next few slides
but basically it's a scaling goal like d
arbitrary large you can learn it with a
bigger samples
um and so with this definition we have
like the following
uh learnability certificate uh for smart
function
so sr is sgd learnable in audi scaling
if your risk is dynamically reachable
from this
initialization in dfpb
and this is just because of this
boundary
so like uh okay
we have this definition just i mean like
it's equivalent to this uh
like dfid being able to reach uh zero
risk
from like um
first layer weights initialized to you
are there any questions
where does the degree
come
yes
it will depend on ps2
so i'm not tracking the dependency
so
i mean i comment more about this uh then
we're talking about constant sparsity
then yeah
but then we can do
you know with kernels also
so
yeah you need it to the in my result you
can do sufficiently so
okay yeah yeah so so i i we can okay
sure
do you want to do it linear and you're
supposed to be
the other power key yes
um so yeah henry can allow from pr
figuring so here is just a clear if i
fix p okay
yeah
yeah so so the the thing is like we need
deer
like sufficiently laughs them
right so like uh pick and grow like
slowly with respect to this so i think
uh currently the the proof uh
that we have like a lot for log log the
uh
uh figuring out
okay i need to
go faster
uh okay so this uh animatron simulation
so we take uh the degree four staircase
uh so d equals 300 and equal 500
uh and so i compare batch sgd with the
dfpd solution
uh so the batch lgd is in the color
continuous line and uh gfpd is this
dotted black line and so on the left i
plotted the tester on the right and
plotted the
fourier coefficients
so you see that here you have the fpd i
chose like zero error
and uh so in particular it means that f
star is sgd learnable in audi scaling
here
and uh for
linear models you would need
d at the power four for
samples
and features and random features and
fixed features
so here you have like again yeah from
linux to the other power for
edges
not negligible
um okay
so can we understand which parts f-star
is gg learnable in od spinning
and so
we'll introduce the merged staircase
property
that would be a generalization of the
vanilla circuit property so we take
f-star we decompose it into in his
fourier coefficients
and we do not queue
all the non-zero fourier coefficients
and we say that star has the merge
staircase property
if we can write the elements of q in
order s one to sr
and so that
for any j uh sj add only at most one
element to the
support of the previous
as ice
and so lecture is for a few examples to
make it more complete so for example for
this first one it's like the degree
fourth staircase and so at each monomial
you only add one new coordinate to this
support
uh same here so you have like the two
and
it is z1 z2 this is for like one degree
monomials
uh examples of non-msp functions are
those so for example to go from z1 to
z1z to this three you add
two coordinates
at the time so okay then speed
and uh so we have two simple
prepositions so non-msp target functions
f-star are not as reliable in audi
scanning
and this has a very simple reason is
again using the certificate uh so dfpg
doesn't reach zero risk
and uh
and the reason here is because the
weights ut during the dft dynamics or
base like
a u3t equal use for t equals zero
so basically a
system is never fitted
and so you have uh dfpd trapped on the
center point
and uh here i remarked that
okay d bigger than exponential in t is
necessary
because if you fix d
and wait long enough lgd will escape at
this other point and so here is a
simulation with this particular function
and so like z one z two z two z four
you're supposed to open it and after
some time you start running it
and uh actually
for this function we have a conjecture
that it's
hd learnable in od squared scanning and
so here basically it would correspond to
waiting t proportional to d
that's just like well that's what
happened
uh so whatever to converse
so when our msp learned
so the adventure of this dfpg is that
it's like really easy to assimilate so
here are a few examples so the two upper
examples seems to be
learn and the two bottom
line wants them to be learned and so
what is happening for these two so here
you can see that
the target functions are a permutation
symmetric in the first three coordinates
so it means that
uh u1 will be equal to u2 for us3 during
the dynamics
uh so what happens when you break the to
symmetry
and uh yeah
this that happens so you start learning
this function
and uh actually analytical now
it's not so
yeah so when you pattern the
coefficients
and you break the symmetry it is msp
uh like uh like the function is learned
with the symmetry it's not very well i
mean no just like this and i think you
can actually like show it
um
okay so actually eric will show that uh
non-degenerate msp are invulnerable
okay
okay
hi uh so to recapitulate we are trying
to learn some function target function
at star it depends on p inputs and p
should be thought of as constant as t
goes to infinity
and zero describes the dimension free pe
which in the mean field a limit describe
the two layer uh uh
training dynamics and he's given a
necessary condition that you must
satisfy this merged staircase property
to be learnable and so now i'm gonna do
in the last uh ten minutes is talk about
sufficient conditions for learnability
and the first uh thing
i don't have too much time but i'll give
you a bit of a flavor from the proof
is going to be to prove that if you have
uh you know some number of neurons that
grows a little faster than a constant
and the number of samples that's around
d
you can learn uh this vanilla staircase
and in fact you can learn this vanilla
staircase for p sufficiently slow
growing
but in particular a kernel method would
need d to the p samples and the mean
field dynamics can get around that i get
past that and allow you to learn it in
uh roughly d samples and then the second
theorem which i'm not going to get into
so much detail is in fact uh converse uh
in a smooth complexity setting to what
theo said and i'm gonna prove that any
function
uh that which satisfies this msp
property and the coefficients are quote
unquote non-degenerate will be uh
actually learnable uh in this uh
in this scale
and so
since the the
dimension of free pd is tough to analyze
instead we'll analyze this leovise
training which uh just means we're gonna
first
initialize the neural network and first
inputs we'll also initialize the first
layer of the neural network to zero
since uh
it doesn't matter
and it simplifies this proof
and this is the second layer the neural
network will initialize to uniform minus
1 1.
and we're going to first train the first
layer for p steps p is the
sparsity of staircase that's how that's
you'd only need p steps that's enough
constant number of steps
uh and these are the non-linear dynamics
that are tough to analyze and what
they're doing is they're creating new
features so that when we train the
second layer to convergence with some
quadratic regularization we do kernel
ridge regression
on a
set of non-linear features that we've
learned by training the first layer
and uh and so the claim is that this
layer-wise training uh which isn't
exactly what uh the the one pass sgd
that theo was describing uh we'll learn
uh these
uh
these uh
these staircase functions
so let's re restate the source theorem
we're saying it says that the vanilla
staircase is learned by a tubular neural
network training with this layer-wise
green descent as long as you have the
epsilon neurons and due to one plus
epsilon samples
and uh
and and so let's first
just
see how how could we analyze the
generalization error well let's see what
happens when you train the second layer
since this is a kernel ridge regression
we can apply standard bounds
um
to bound to generalization error
and particularly by adapting some
standard kernel ridge regression
generalization balance we can prove that
it suffices to show that after
training the first layer
the uh it suffices to show that there's
some certificate so some setting of the
way to the second layer that would be
low norm and would also uh end up giving
you low population risk and then in that
case this kernel visual regression uh
will also give you uh
vanishing risk with high power
and so this will be the remainder of the
proof we're going to show that there's
such a certificate
and so now we're going to analyze what
happens when you train the first layer
so because of the mean field limit uh
let's just skip over these you can uh
you can prove that uh the when you train
the first layer you're going to converge
to some limiting dynamics and so
essentially
for the it'll suffice to analyze the
following idealized train dynamics where
uh we're just training the fir the first
layer we're keeping the second layer a
fixed
so for each neuron we're evolving it in
this way
and particularly this term depends only
on the uh limiting
distribution of the number of neurons
and samples goes to infinity and since
it's always uh it's very small because
we're uh taking a relatively small but
constant learning rate
we can essentially uh
ignore it and so for the purposes of
this talk let's just analyze these
training index
so just
what happens let's try to see what
happens when you train
this well
another assumption we'll make but which
can be removed is that uh sigma is a
polynomial
and so time t
uh
the
weights are all zero
and after one step
uh the weights uh have now picked up the
coefficient in x1
and particularly you can see this by
writing the update equation as an inner
product between the staircase function
that you're trying to learn and the uh
and x i this is the optic equation for
the ice coefficient uh the coefficient
of x
i and after two steps now you can see
that the the
weights of uh
the first uh the coefficient of the
first
of x1 is going to be a
some polynomial with the degree one term
in the second layer weights and the
coefficient of x2 will be a problem of
degree two
secondary term
in particular after uh
p steps of this training procedure
in general you can prove that the
weights that you think
are all given by polynomials in the
second layer weights which have this
algebraic structure
okay
and uh this allows you to then prove
that the uh matrix of features that you
construct as a training uh is
non-singular with high probability
because this matrix is going to be a
determinant in the second layer weights
so if you plug in the random uh
weights of the second layer uh
you're going to get to know the
non-singular matrix
which can be inverted and give you the
certificate that it needed
and so that's a proof sketch for
learning this vanilla staircase
uh
to prove that the non-degenerate merged
therapies property suffices a similar
proof will work
uh will be
whether the more uh
full statement of this theorem is that
uh
given a uh
msp
function f
if you
perturb each of the coefficients by most
some arbitrarily small constant tau then
you'll learn
with this layer wise green descent
and again we use the same kind of
algebraic techniques although
slightly more sophisticated arguments
are needed for this
and so overall we have this meta theorem
combining the necessity result that you
presented and uh
this uh theme that i've just
run over which says that uh with this
number total number of samples roughly d
uh two-layer mean-field networks will
learn a piece-based function if and only
if it satisfies this merged staircase
property with these non-degenerate
coefficients
and uh so just to summarize
uh we've uh explained that the staircase
property plays some role in
understanding what regular neural
networks can learn
uh
the emmanuel presented a lower bound
against kernel methods uh
uh theo presented this dimension free pd
uh which
allows one to simulate and determine
whether a function will be learned
or not and then uh now i've
quickly presented uh
a converse to the necessary condition
that he
uh presents
so that's uh our talk thank you
[Applause]
uh
it's great and we can clarify a bit so
what's the epstein there and how
bottom line for your positive result
how many
uh
neurons and how many how much data do
you need
right uh epsilon there is really just
for convenience of stating this uh we
can we could probably prove this with uh
uh
where is this
okay so
uh we take a number of neurons that's
just large enough constant essentially
and we take uh
uh sorry number of samples
let's say it depends on p presumably
every p is constant so okay
the only thing that grows in this uh
setting is d they put them in so number
three is some something depends on p but
does not depend on d
uh yes okay it's a large enough console
right
and then yeah
and
and what's epsilon just epsilon is an
arbitrarily small uh concept it just
hides log terms okay in india
what what's the non-degenerate position
yeah the non-degenerate condition
is uh
basically that
we have a function that satisfies this
merge stereo this property we can write
it as a multi-linear polynomial the
non-degenerate condition is that uh if
we perturb these uh
coefficients of the these fourier
coefficients uh randomly with some
any small
constant uh
uh noise then we'll get a non-degenerate
uh
uh function
uh what's it not degenerate function i
don't know okay so if we begin with f f
star which is uh some
multi-linear polynomial with a
sparsity pattern on its fourier
coefficients which satisfies this merged
staircase property and we perturb the
non-zero uh
fourier coefficients with
epsilon small noise then we can prove
that we can learn the resulting the
resulting function is learned is learned
so in some sense it was it works without
probability when respecting the
classification
so it's a smooth analysis saying any
arbitrary
merge staircase property function that
you begin with if you perturb it uh
uh slightly you will get a function that
is learnable
i think maybe we should you can mention
can you hear me actually yeah so if you
have a function like x1 plus x2 plus x3
and then plus the product of the three
it creates a difficulty for the units to
to learn because you know the three
first monomials are competing
and so uh it seems like uh you know this
this perfect symmetry
uh makes it that it takes a lot of time
or doesn't manage to learn
uh if you're not on the sub space so
it's really a
chat session
this number of units does not grow
uh the number of units doesn't have to
grow with uh
because this is a piece bars function uh
and i think they're actually in general
you might only need constant i'm not
sure
so
small n is the number of samples so
capital n is just uh bigger than a
constant infinity is bigger than a
constant
so so
okay so for example like so there exists
a concept you know so that
and bigger than this constant and degree
to infinity
absolutely
because to get the approximation you do
have to get
so it will depend on
yeah this star will depend on p so it
will be like the time to convergence it
is
dimension three or e
yeah uh so it will depend on p and maybe
exponentially
yeah
so like for the positive result
we actually have a
bound explicit down in
p
which is uh
yeah everything has to scale like a
double exponential
number of samples
yeah
so basically the statement would be like
d is bigger than
i i mean number of samples bigger than d
times exponential of exponential
in the previous paper with the much um
less uh standard neural network but so
regular under our definition we had uh
scaling uh we could grow we could run
antennas polynomial in np
so we could have but this is also the
and there the depths is growing with
these
so it's not clear that this double
exponential is okay maybe it's not it
can be improved but probably there is an
exponential dependency if you are only
two layers
i mean
to go back to your first question nattie
if p grows like log log d
this is still a case in a case where you
have a polynomial scaling uh whereas for
kernels you will not be able to learn so
it does give a separation
and and now if you still stick to just
depth 2
and in this midfield it's not clear that
you don't have to pay
with an exponential scaling
if you don't go with deeper models yeah
okay
there are no further questions thanks uh
[Applause]
the second thought for this morning
talking all by himself
the second talk will be given by uh
andrea and i actually he'll tell us